or it avec nous l'aurions voulait
d'abord revenir avec toi sur certaines
images qui ont marqué ta carrière
ton rêve au départ ce n'était pas du
tout la chanson c'est le patinage
artistique comme moi j'y fais huit
heures de patinage artistique non mais
c'est vrai c'est avec surya bonaly a
patiné on ce qui fait tu commences à 6
ans et tout hutin très bon niveau
regarde on a on a retrouvé des images de
toits petit quand tu patines regarde
regarde
[Musique]
alors ya une blessure qui vient casser
ton rêve c'est vrai voilà et donc
c'était tu t'es blessé où je me suis
fracturé le ménisque ah ouais donc la
terminer n'ont pas terminé mais en fait
comme j'ai coûté rien et que j'en
faisais qu'à ma tête
le chirurgien après l'opération avait
dit six à huit mois de rééducation
sauf qu'au bout d'un mois vu que deux
mois après c'était les championnats de
france au bout d'un mois je suis
retourné sur les patins et je me suis
cassé une deuxième fois et voilà quoi
bon aujourd'hui tu regardes tu rien tu
patines toujours comme ça pour le kiff
oui marre ça fait très longtemps que
j'ai pas rechaussé les patins mais
n'inquiète pas me fâcher le mcs a study
mais à l'époque où j'étais sûr il a une
patinoire alors aujourd'hui tu viens
nous voir pour c'est pas si compliqué
mais astuces pour positiver le quotidien
est-ce que tu as trois astuces à donner
aux téléspectateurs pour positiver voilà
les trois astuces voilà surtout en ce
moment pour positiver ce serait quoi
surtout en ce moment c'est de se dire
que ce cette mauvaise période va se
terminer un jour en fait et c'est de
voir le bout du tunnel
et c'est de se faire du bien de la
méditation du sport bien manger pendant
des parias cette période compliquée
comme ça parce que si on n'est pas bien
ce moment là physiquement mentalement
journée c'est pas bon quand ça risque
d'être compliqué ouais donc les yaaku
alors vas-y parce que non mais voilà
s'il ya une astuce a retiré la nos
téléspectateurs c'est une p ya pas une
maintenant parce que quoi tous les
magasins food chose qui est qui peut
correspondre à plein de personnes
différentes ce matin c'est quoi le
premier geste à faire chanter ni se
laver les dents on est 2 sur 4 à faire
ici dans son lit tu donne donc des
astuces pour positiver sur la vie on va
voir si ça la portée de tout le monde je
vous donnais des situations qui sont de
vraies galères à vous de les positives
et laurie dommage t'appelle pour te
proposer de reprendre sur un air latino
mais en mode sur un air pépito comment
tu réagis basse et revenantes à ça me
fait rire très bien donc on le sait
benjamin castaldi votre couple pas mal
aurore est jalouse de votre poitrine et
des sites vous quittez vous réagissez
comme bon très bien dans quoi si votre
femme vous quitte non mais c'est normal
c'est normal qu'elle soit heureuse de ma
poitrine qui est de plus en plus
proéminente isabelle rtl dégringole en
audience france inter accepte de vous
reprendre à la seule condition que vous
admettiez qui sont numéro un en audience
pour agissez comme en aba j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] de france inter d'entrée sur tous
et dégringole je reste à airtel
bon c'est calme vous voulez faire une
nouvelle coupe de cheveux et soraya
notre coiffeuse qui je précise ne nous a
jamais montré de son stylo vous fait une
couleur vert caca d'oie comment
réagissez-vous h humeur derrière jacques
tiff
j'ai simplement gravés j'adore très bien
philippe une femme je vous plais chaud
mais elle se rend vite compte que en
fait aussi en fait si vous n'êtes pas
philippe lellouche mais vous n'êtes pas
philippe lellouche mais jean michel
lemaire en fait à vous a confondu et
jean michel maire est-ce que vous sortez
avec elle quand même maintenant
j'appelle jean-michel non c'est comme ça
vaut ouais alors vous savez que soraya
notre coiffeuse est très amoureuse de
vous non vraiment c'est brian est très
très bien je leur ai je la remercie du
fond du coeur
virginie pour la mille sept cent
cinquantième fois depuis que vous faites
de la télé je vous demande de faire le
crapaud que réagissez vous
[Rires]
mais pas d'éclats
si vous voulez que je me fais de
l'animal j'ai envie à chaque fois que
vous avez envi ron oui ni oui ni crapaud
c'est dur je vous pose des questions
mais c'est le conservatoire en belgique
on est en égypte options de textes on
doit pouvoir faire un animal et j'avais
choisi le crapaud et j'ai été pris le
premier tour
ces jeux et mais moi je peux l'avoir
sans fouras